Good evening everyone. I now call to
order this special meeting uh work
session of Lancaster City Council for
August 19th, 2025. A few reminders for
all of you uh as we get started. This
meeting and its participants are being
recorded. This is a non-legislative
working session of council this evening.
Public comment will be taken at the end
of the meeting on topics related to this
evening's presentation uh of the
administrative code. As always, comments
are limited to three minutes per speaker
and must begin with your name and block
of residence for our meeting record.
Also, as a reminder, questions on these
sections of the admin code will be taken
uh after tonight's meeting by both the
public and by council. We'll get a
review of the timing uh at the end of
the meeting.
Members of council, we have one piece of
business before we begin our
presentation. That's the approval of the
minutes of our July 15, 2025
administrative code working session.
You've been provided a copy of those
minutes. I'll hear a motion.
Motion to approve.
Second. We have a motion and a second.
Counselors, are there any comments on
those minutes?
Hearing none. Mr. Harris, if you would.
Madam President, do we uh want to do a
roll call members?
I apologize. As soon as I said that, I
realized I had not officially taken a
role. So, we'll put a pause on that and
we will take the roll call of members.
Thank you for keeping us straight, Mr.
Harris.
Mr. Med
here.
Mr. Royo
Mr. Cle
here.
Miss Craig
Miss Diaz.
Mr. Hirsh
here. President Baker
here. Thank you very much. We'll now
pick up that motion to approve the
minutes of our uh last administrative
code working session on July 15th. We
have a motion and a second. Any council
comments on the minutes?
Hearing none. Mr. Harris.
Mr. M.
I.
Mr. Royer.
Mr. Please.
I.
Miss. Craig.
Mr. H.
And President Baker.
I. Thank you so much. All right. That
will take us into tonight's
presentation. Mr. Henburgger, back goes
to you.
Good evening. Just as a reminder, this
is our second, I'll call it trunch of
the admin code. So, we presented first
um uh over a two-month period preceding
this. And this is the second trunch. And
again, just as a reminder of where we're
coming from, this is a starting point.
Um, not a mandate that you adopt it in
any format that it's currently in, but
this is the starting point for
discussion. Um, most of the provisions
that you'll see tonight came from one of
several places. Um, either existing
ordinance, and I'll try and note where
that is as we get through them. Um,
existing third class city code that we
may not be bound by, but which we deem
to be good practice, current practices.
um in some cases state law and in some
places just recommendations based on
seeing other u municipalities um uh not
just in Pennsylvania but other places
how they deal with various items and
recommendations excuse me again for you
to um consider as you move through the
administrative code process and again
you're going to see as we get later on a
a holding place here for the ethics code
and just as a report to council uh the
ethics commission has held its first
meeting and we'll be advertising and
scheduling two meetings in September uh
shortly um and hopes to uh with the
hopes that they'll be getting
recommendations for things for you to
include in your draft of the ethics
code. Uh the charter does specifically
require you to draft the ethics code and
um the practice that we've tried here is
to put it uh into the administrative
code which is a common practice. not
always done that way, but it is a common
practice. Um, so that you're getting
everything done at one time um and in
one place. Uh, and with that, what I'll
do is, as we did last time, I'm going to
walk you through um what you've now been
provided um electronically um so that
you can review it in detail. And
tonight's uh discussion for me is meant
to be a broad overview. Um there will be
obviously specifics in the language that
you'll want to review as you go forward.
Um
and keeping in mind that uh ultimately
this is going to be adopted by ordinance
which again means that it can be changed
by ordinance. So it's part of the
flexibility that the home rule option
gives us as local governments. It's the
greatest form of local governments
unlike the third class city code. You
don't get to elect in or out of any
provision at any time here. uh this is
your starting point and uh future
generations of this council may find
that things need to be changed and can
so change it. Um so these are the
sections we didn't talk about last time
in the first trunch and the first one
and and these are sections quite frankly
that fit a little bit more at home with
what you're used to seeing and and used
to doing. They cover a lot of what you
do regularly. So we're going to start
with organizational structure um article
three departments and officials. Um the
home rule charter uh law and the charter
provide that we need to lay out in the
administrative code um what the
departments and organizational structure
of the government is. Um the charter
lays out that the city is going to have
seven council members and a controller
um along with the mayor as being the
elected officials of the city. The
charter also requires that the city have
a department of administrative services
and such other departments as may be um
authorized by ordinance of city council
from time to time. That's what section
two of article 3 is covering. And Mr.
Harris, you can move to that page for
reference here. So, we're beyond the
table of contents and we're right into
the into the charter here. Um so, again,
you're going to see that there are
several departments and what we're
calling um uh major administrative
units. Those major administrative units
are the office of the mayor, the bureau
of police and bureau of fire. Um and
then we have um our departments.
Um each department um is to be headed by
a director or chief um appointed as set
forth in the charter. Um who has duties
under the direction of the mayor to uh
run their department uh in accordance
with the ordinances of the city, state
law, the administrative code, uh
prescribe the internal organization of
the department or major administrative
unit uh and the duties of subordinate
officers and employees within those
departments. Uh we can go to the next
page.
um obviously to assign powers to their
employees to direct and supervise the
work of their employees. And again, a
lot of this is what we would expect.
It's just never been legislatively uh
laid out um report um at least annually
or such times as council deems necessary
to the mayor and council. Um and this is
a relatively new requirement, but one I
think that is of best practice, which is
we actually do do it. It's done during
your budget process, but it's really
tied into the budget. And this is if
council wants to elect a different
format of reporting, it could. Um,
paragraphs eight and nine of this
section dealing with the police chief
and fire chief. These are provisions
taken from our existing city ordinances.
Um, uh, chapters 42 and 67 of the code
which deal with fire and police. Um
we talk about here the um concept of if
a director can't serve for a short
period of time. Um the mayor being able
to designate a deputy but that being a
very limited a deputy to serve but that
being for a very limited time before
they have to appear before council um
and make sure that council has vetted
them for continuation. And that is
different than the appointment of an
interim um director which is essentially
intended to be somebody outside the city
and for a um a longer period of time
than say the 90 days. So um an example
of this would be um the hiring of uh we
hired an interim police chief a while
back um and then moved forward with an
internal hire at a later time. So, um,
that's a provision that we've added for
your consideration, um, is is how to how
to deal with sort of, uh, making sure
services are continued through the use
of a deputy. Um, next page, B.
Other appointed officials covers the
appointed officials set forth in the
charter. Um, and it also includes a
provision that the charter left
specifically for council to determine,
which is the roles and obligations of
the city engineer. And what has been
suggested here is that role may change
over time. It's changed over time here
at the city. Um, there was one point
where we had one city engineer and maybe
no others. Now we have multiple
engineers working in multiple bureaus.
They're not necessarily all working
under the direction of one engineer.
They may be working under different
bureau chiefs. So the concept that's
been proposed here at least as a
starting point is that um with the
appointment of the city engineer uh the
mayor will be recommending uh for city
council to adopt a resolution appointing
that individual and setting forth the
roles of the city engineer um at that
time. So for example, right now one of
the things that we know needs to be done
with somebody who has authority is you
know signing certain stamps and putting
certain stamps on documents. Um if
ultimately uh our departments
reorganized such that there would be a
full bureau of engineering where all
engineers were supervised by one
engineer, it is entirely plausible that
at that point we might want the city
engineer to be the head of that bureau.
Um it's left again here flexib
flexibility. Um if you want to prescribe
something more obviously you can but
this is the starting point for
suggestion. Uh the next section and you
can turn the page B um is the
organizational chart that will exist um
on December January 1st 2026.
Um as you as you know currently we have
a treasurer. The charter eliminated the
position of treasurer but the elected
treasurer's term doesn't end until this
end of this calendar year. So this this
uh uh organizational chart reflects what
will happen when that position no longer
exists which would be at the termination
of the elected uh treasurer's term. Um
ultimately with adoption we'd probably
insert a note if this is adopted
obviously prior to the excuse me to the
end of the year uh that this chart is
meant to go into effect you know upon uh
the termination of the treasurer's uh
current role.
section five and section six. Um,
essentially I've referenced these are
are your existing ordinances in chapters
42 and 67 of our code dealing with uh
provisions specific to the Bureau of
Police and Bureau of Fire. Uh, one thing
to note um in the Bureau of Police is a
proposed change uh regarding uh who the
um officers are. Currently we have uh
ranks which are um sergeant, lieutenant
and captain and then there are assigned
positions which include detectives. Uh
the proposal here is to make detective
rank um and make that its appointment to
be detective to be subject to civil
service just like sergeants and
lieutenants are. Um this um
uh does a couple of things. It's it's of
benefit to our and I believe to our city
police officers and that they now have
an objective standard by which um
promotion to the rank of detective would
be handled. It assures that the
promotion process is handled the same
way as sergeants and lieutenants which
is through a civil service project
hopefully assuring qualification uh and
and objectivity towards the selection.
Um it does not eliminate all um
discretion from the appointing powers as
again it's a group of three um and the
appointing power can select um from that
group the member on that list they wish
to fill the vacancy in that position. Um
but again this is uh this is the way our
sergeants and lieutenants have
historically been promoted. Um, and uh,
from both a functional and legal
perspective, I believe it's the best way
for detectives to be handled. The chief
of police obviously concurs or it would
not be in here. Um, so that that's a
significant one the one significant
change in this provision from uh, what
you would see if you were to review the
police uh, code. Um, with respect to
fire, the one um, primary change is in
and again you can flip the pages here,
Bernard. um um is right there in D um
which uh I believe the last time the
fire ordinance was amended was
relatively long ago and no one looked at
that provision in D um which included
the the number of fire chiefs, deputy
chiefs, battalion chiefs, captains um it
was way high. So um this is uh these are
the numbers that were recommended by the
fire chief and um uh
currently um the number of officers we
have now um in terms of one fire chief,
one deputy chief, four battalion chiefs,
four captains, one of one of which would
s serve as the captain of the fire
marshals uh and 12 lieutenants um with
the concept that you wouldn't fall below
that number. So, it's sort of keeping um
uh where we're at but not going below.
And again, this is an ordinance so can
be changed. Um and this is discussion
point for start.
Um and again, the rest of that section
is essentially uh almost identical to
what's in your existing city ordinances.
Um, as you move to section seven, civil
service,
a lot of this will seem somewhat
repetitive to what's in the previous two
sections regarding fire and um, police,
but this is essentially the civil
service law um, that's in place. and it
it goes into a little bit more detail
than what's in our fire and police
ordinances and in those sections um and
deals with the provisions of civil
service as they relate to our fire and
police uh appointments and promotions.
That moves us to article six which is
city council. Um and you may be aware
that um chapter 55 of the city code
currently governs a lot of the
activities of city council and much of
the information if not almost all of it
has been incorporated here. Uh including
as you'll note paragraph F which is the
agenda of meetings. Um no
recommendations have been made for that.
Um again that that's just incorporated.
That's council's pleasure to determine
whether they wish to discuss that. Um
what's been put in here um in section
two are requirements again that we um
hold our meetings in conformity with
both the the charter and applicable law
which includes the Sunshine Act. Um
again that we make sure we keep our
minutes in accordance with those laws.
Um uh note that we publish or advertise
our meetings in accordance with
applicable law. Um it maintains the uh
provisions for appointment of the
president of council. Um, it
incorporates the charter requirements um
that meetings be held uh um between uh 6
pm and 9 pm and incorporates the current
6:30 p.m. start. Um and that's also
consistent with the charter. Um
paragraph G um incorporates provisions
of the Sunshine Act regarding um uh
public comment. Um it it talks about
rollover rules of orders again which are
in chapter 55 um and talks about how
members can speak. Again that's all
provisions that you'll see consistent
with chapter 55 of our code. Um
one thing to note in the last paragraph
of uh this section G
chapter 55 has a provision that I'm not
sure how to interpret as an attorney.
The current provision says that you can
wave the provisions, your rules and
regulations at a particular meeting upon
a twothirds vote. But I find twothirds
very difficult to calculate when you
have a council of seven or five or four.
The division doesn't work
mathematically. The last I checked,
people are whole and so decimal points
and fractions don't work real well. Um
what I've proposed here is a way to make
it clear which is majority plus one of
the members at attendance at the
meeting. So for example, if you had
seven in order to wave any sort of
requirement. So I'll use the example you
have a threeminut requirement. The
council decides for the purpose of this
meeting we want to wave that three
minute requirement. You would need a
vote of five members at that time in
order to do it. If you had five members
present, you would need four. Again, not
allowing um just the general politics of
a majority, but taking what I think was
the original chapter 55's concept of a
supermajority, but putting it to a
number we can actually calculate, which
is a majority of members present plus
one. And again, that's for your
consideration. These are just ways of
sort of bringing what we currently do uh
and maybe making them a little bit
cleaner. Uh section three um again
incorporates the ability to create
committees. Um talks about the time for
committees, committees requirements um
to comply with the Sunshine Act relating
to public meetings and the keeping of
minutes. Um
requiring the the notice of meetings and
the and the um minutes of meetings to be
posted on our publicly accessible
website.
um
allowing council members to be appointed
to serve on boards and commissions or
authorities. So, for example, if we have
a board that does say we should have a
member of council on it, we obviously
want to make sure that's allowed. Uh one
of the things that paragraph E does do,
however, is say that look, if that board
member, that council member's term as a
council member expires, their membership
on that board commission authority
should also expire. Right? like the
reason they were appointed was not as
one of the general appointments, but as
the council representative and so if
they're no longer on council, council
would need to replace them with a
council representative.
Um section four is is simply a matter to
confirm law, which is to indicate that
council is a continuous body, meaning
that as your membership changes every
two, potentially changes every two
years, um the acts of council in each
version bind the other. So like it's
still the action of council and not well
it's a new council so we don't have to
follow what the old council did. No I
mean you have to follow it unless you
change it by ordinance resolution or
appropriate motion as would be
appropriate in this situation.
Section five talks about filling
vacancies. This is our current practice.
It's also the practice in the third
class city code. Uh and it's the pract
it's the language from the charter. What
I note here is that there's been no
procedure for council to follow in
filling vacancies, whether that be on
council, uh the office of um the mayor,
the office of the controller, all of
which can happen based on the charter,
if there's a vacancy. Um you have an
option here if you want to legislate
what the process of council should be.
Um whether that be we're going to go
through public interviews, we're going
to put it, you know, ask for
nominations, however that is. I've left
this to be your pleasure. I've seen it
done differently by different versions
of this council and other councils many
times over 35 years. I I did not want to
presume to make a recommendation. Um, so
I've left it um which is current which
is you can decide each time or if if a
member of council wants to propose
legislation to add here they
um section six uh incorporates both
provisions of a charter and a current
resol and existing resolution of council
requiring training um for members of
council. Section seven again is um a
requirement to take the oath of counsel.
Section eight and nine are new and are
meant really as discussion points for
you. Um not necessarily recommendations
but also really points to consider. Um
section 8 deals with the power to
maintain order. Um and allows uh would
allow council president to have um
individuals removed from the room who
are not complying with council policy.
and if a council member was doing the
same to suspend or terminate the
meeting. Um again these are these this
is a provision that appears in many uh
uh admin codes and other similar codes.
It's something here for thought. Uh
section nine is also for thought which
is um we talk about excused and
unexcused absences but what is the
penalty for that? there really isn't one
because you can't you can't make
somebody forfeit their office or lose
their office. Um so uh the thought here
is if council wanted to have a provision
where whatever compensation um council
members are receiving they had some sort
of financial limitation on that. In
other words, some loss of their
compensation if they had a certain
number of unexcused absences. So nine is
is an attempt to start to discuss that.
Um section 10 um is a lot of what I
think we already do. It's never it's not
in legislation. It's sort of an
expectation that you have for one
another already, but hasn't been
legislatively placed. Again, you don't
have to put this here. This is these are
things that I think most of you would
say in most cases we we do and we should
do. So, we're talking about conduct and
staff communications. You know, it's
it's maintaining decorum. It's preparing
themselves for public issues. Listening
courteously
uh courteously and attentively
um you know and and avoiding debate
during public comment. Public comment is
for public comment. Um following
procedures adopted by council and
refraining from interrupting others
while speaking. um you know making sure
that um you uh are clear as to your
opinion versus council's opinion, right?
Um no one can say what council's opinion
is unless council has voted on it or
adopted a resolution or ordinance. So
again, these this is as much meant for
people that might want to become members
of council to understand what their
roles and obligations are uh and make
sure they go into it with clear eyes and
to help guide those who are actually on
council might have to think wait a
minute do I have a different expectation
of how I react in this setting than in
others. Um you know it's about how I can
respond to citizens in writing and what
sort what I can say on letterhead and
what are my responsibilities.
um you know obviously a requirement
which is common sense not making false
statements you know to that other
council members are going to rely upon.
Um and then you know uh basic uh
courtesy in dealing with city employees
because under the um structure that the
charter is adopted which is you're the
legislative body and then the
administration is under the supervision
of the mayor and the employees are
technically under the supervision of the
mayor for both legal and practical
purposes. making sure that it's clear
what roles you can or can't have in
terms of communications with staff. And
most of these are really common sense.
Um but again, they're here for your
view, discussion, and thought. Um we
then move to um article seven, which is
rule uh ordinances, resolutions. And
again, a lot of this is what we're
already doing. It's already in city
ordinance. It's already in the third
class city code. Um we already we do
have a mandated two reading requirement
that comes from the charter and uh past
practice. Um a lot of the provisions
regarding ordinance and numbering of
ordinances are the same. One thing I'll
note here is in um
section one part B number four is
something that I'm suggesting
um which I think will help uh staff
council members and more importantly um
uh citizens and interested parties in
your legislation which is the
requirement of a memo with the
introduction. So if a council member or
the staff is introducing either and
obviously both can do that right uh
ordinance uh producing with that
original version of the ordinance a memo
that that answers some key questions. Um
this is similar to the way the state
adopts legislation and the federal
government. So there's actually you're
starting to create a legislative history
um and an explanation as to what is the
issue or problem the ordinance is
intended to address and how was it
brought to the attention of the city or
council. Um are there areas in the city,
if any, where the issue um or the
problem is more predominant? What are
the impacts of that issue or problem?
Does any data exist relating to the
issue or problem? What is the source of
the data? Um what are the intended
benefits and outcomes of the proposed
legislation? Are there any existing
ordinances which address the issues or
problems and if so why are they
insufficient or inefficient? Um can we
confirm that compliance with the
proposed ordinance will not cause undue
burden on any sector of the community?
How and by whom will the ordinance be
enforced? I can tell you having drafted
a lot of ordinances for municipalities
over the years, this is oftentimes a
forgotten about provision. Um, unfunded
mandates as as sometimes we like to
refer to them. Um, how frequently should
data from enforcement be reviewed by
council, staff or both? And is there any
reporting required by of staff or
council? Um, and how does state and or
federal law impact the proposed
legislation? These are all from my
perspective basic questions that council
should always be aware of when any
ordinance is introduced. Um, but to
actually memorialize it as a requirement
to do so, make sure that the public gets
that information. Um, and also puts a
level of due diligence on ordinance
drafting, right? It's it's it can't
simply be a very fast reactionary sort
of process. There needs to be some
thought uh and look to make sure that
we're doing it right. If you take a look
at our code of ordinances, you will see
things that were drafted piece by piece
over time in reaction to certain things.
That doesn't mean they're bad, but like
can we go and find legislatively why it
was done? It's going to be really a
challenge. Um here now we would be able
to track back historically
um and because these would become
permanent records of the city and part
of uh the ordinance record we would be
able to track the reasoning which would
be helpful when we get to the point
where somebody questions what about this
ordinance why isn't it be used how did
it come you know all of those types of
things so um I'm encouraging this one
this is this is a recommendation from me
um I did a presentation to council a
number of years ago uh dealing with
similar topics and I had a much larger,
broader length of questions. The mayor
helped me craft those down. Um, giving
credit where credit is due. Um, to what
I think is is is really actually
reasonable um and not undo work. It's
not creating paper for the point of
creating paper sake. It's actually
creating paper for the point of
producing a better ordinance.
Uh, section B, reading advertisement and
enactment of ordinances. This
incorporates our existing practice of
two readings. Um, one thing I will note
is um, with ordinances under the third
class city code, we're required to
advertise an ordinance um, in the
Lancaster newspapers prior to adoption.
If any of you have ever looked, those
notices appear in the classified
section. Um, and they're little blurbs
and uh, not always the most easy to find
uh, legal notices. Um
the charter left it open to advertising
um publicly accessible website or other
methods chosen by council. This does not
apply to notices of meetings. Meetings
still must be advertised in the
Lancaster newspaper um under the
Sunshine Act. What's in the
administrative code here is a proposal
that we utilize the publicly accessible
website um for posting them. um
requirements later on that they be
posted in a very clear um and easily
easy to find location um so that it's
not sort of hiding the ball in another
place. Uh that will be one of the last
sections we talk about tonight, but I
note for your consideration that's been
put here. There's been a lot of
discussion about do people really read
the legal notices? Um is it a worthwhile
expenditure of the city? Um what's the
best way to get notice out? That's
really what this is about, right? I
mean, when we talk about advertising the
ordinances, we're talking about the best
way to notify the public
uh of something that's coming. The
Sunshine Act requires us to post the
agenda at least 24 hours in advance of
the meeting. We have to notify the
public of an adoption of an ordinance at
least seven days prior uh under the
charter. Um how we do that is really the
question here. Um and I'm not saying
that this you might choose to do
otherwise. This is just a place where I
see that technology might be of
assistance here. Um, I note that there
is a downfall with that, right? So, what
happens if the website went down? I
would tell you that that would be an a
prohibition to you taking action on
ordinance, which is more encouragement
to make sure that the city keeps
technology, which everybody relies on,
um, properly acting and working as it's
supposed to. But that is one of the
risks. Um just like if you know you
didn't add in the newspaper in time you
would have the same. Um so uh you know
next page resolutions really follows um
our current practice current third class
city law. Section three, proof and
evidence. Proof and evidence is a legal
provision that gives courts the
directive that if the uh city clerk
certifies a motion, resolution or
ordinance as being the motion,
resolution, or ordinance of city
council, that that court can take
judicial notice of the fact that it was
actually adopted by city council rather
than if we got into an enforcement
proceeding. And unfortunately, I've had
to do this. I have to drag members of
city council in to actually testify that
they took a certain action, which seems
a little bit contrary to what we would
like to do from a procedural standpoint.
Um, section four just authorizes us to
enforce ordinances quite frankly in the
way that's authorized by law, which is
through fines, penalties, cost, attorney
fees, injunctive relief, and any other
remedy. And most of our ordinances lay
those out. Um, and this is again just
putting that in the administrative code.
Article 8 is an entirely new procedure
and this one is mandated by the charter.
So the charter has a number of
provisions that uh lead to council being
able to determinate determine that an
elected official should have their
office forfeited. One thing I will note
legally is that council can't effectuate
that. In other words, they can determine
that somebody should have their office
forfeited, an elected official for the
reasons set forth from the charter. But
ultimately, official action needs to be
taken depending on the the reason for
the forfeiture in one of two ways. One
is through a formal impeachment
procedure by the Senate uh the
Pennsylvania Senate, state senate. The
other is what's called a quirronto
procedure either with both of which
would be initiated by the solicitor. So
this procedure what it's doing is
setting forth the way notice would be
given to the um individual who uh
somebody believes council or the
administration believes uh that their
provisions of the charter justify a
forefeiter action. Um their right to
have counsel um when a hearing would be
held, the right to have a hearing. Um
and then directing that um there be a
written decision on that uh produced
within uh 45 days after the hearing is
concluded and that if the decision is
for forefeiter authorizing and directing
the solicitor then to proceed with the
appropriate action at the time whether
that's quote ronto um uh Senate
impeachment or some other procedure that
Pennsylvania law might then adopt. Uh it
also provides a bill provision and
Bernard you can slip page here which is
allowing um there is a there is and this
is consistent with Pennsylvania law.
There is an act called the local agency
law which allows for any act of city
council or the city uh that's finally
determined to be appealed to the court
of common please and this incorporates
that appeal procedure there.
Um we then move to again anated
provision of uh the charter uh from the
charter and the home rule charter law
which is a section on boards,
commissions and authorities. Um most of
this is tracking um what's already in
the charter and what's what's currently
done which is the notice appointment and
vacancies and term for appointment. It's
confirming the charter provision that
appointments are to be made by the mayor
with the consent and advice of counsel
except as otherwise provided by an
applicable law. So if a law says that
the appointment is to be made by the
legislative body, it would be council's
appointment. Um
now even though this says this um it it
does provide uh for the term um and that
vacancies will be filled in the same way
that appointments are made. Um, one new
item is um, a removal clause which does
not exist currently and again this is
again for thought and being very careful
here to note what you can be removed
for. So this should not become a
political item from my perspective. Um
the
um the the only two things that we've
put in here are repeated failure to
attend required meetings, violation of
the ethics code or impropriy in um so
the fact that um you know uh an
appointment to commission border
authority is not doing what the
political leadership thought they should
do is not a reason for their removal. um
that's been built in here and again this
is a starting point for your discussion.
Um and you may choose it maybe there
should be a way to remove them that that
again is your call. It would still be
subject to law but I mean here the
removal then is with the consent of city
council and only after 10 days written
notice.
Sure.
They turn into a pumpkin after so long I
think.
Uh, and moving on with with um most of
all of our ordinances and if you look at
article 22 or chapter 22 of our code,
many of our boards and commissions are
covered in that chapter. There's others
where they're created, but in almost all
cases, um, in accordance with applicable
law, actually, they they give the board
and commission the right to create their
own rules and procedures. What we've
done here is suggest that we clarify
that they still have to comply with the
Sunshine Act. They still have to comply
with the right to know law. Um, that
they have to have advanced notice,
publication, and notification of their
meetings. They have to keep minutes. The
minutes have to be posted on the website
just like city council minutes. Um
um the one thing I'll note here that's
also here is that they can't they can't
just unilaterally choose to use this m
this room or other city facilities like
that needs to be approved by the city
staff. Um and live streaming has to be
approved by the mayor so that we have
control over the use of all of all the
city facilities. Um that's uh what
section F is provided for in uh part F
of section one. Um section two training.
Um this incorporates again um a current
provision by city resolution to have uh
new members and reappointed members get
trained on um
uh specifically currently it covers
sunshine act and right to know law. I've
made this a little broader to help cover
some other topics which might be in fact
some of the laws that they're formed
under um just so they get sort of a a
little broader perspective. Um so it's
it's a little bit broader a little
broader term. Um again section three
requires meetings to be held in
accordance with the Sunshine Act.
Section four, uh, the home rule charter
law and the charter require us to lay
out the authorized boards, commissions,
and authorities, which means that as
those boards and authorities are
changed, you're going to need to, um,
obviously amend this section of the
admin code. Uh, when that happens,
um, section five is similar to what we
talked about with council. Um there is
nothing in the current legislation of
the city current ordinances that deals
with the conduct of board commission. Um
and it should say I think authority
members I think I have committee there.
We'll fix that on a final cleanup. Um
but these are again sort of the same
things that council members are talking
about right like what's decorum again
making sure they understand their
opinions are theirs and not of the
commission um border authority or the
city. Um right um talking about
correspondence. Um again, I'm
reiterating that they may end up in
executive sessions and if information is
given in an executive session, typically
the reason for the executive session is
that our state legislature has
determined that the information that's
going to be discussed should remain
private although the formal action must
be taken in the public meeting. So it's
again inc uh requiring them and
encouraging them to maintain uh that
confidentiality. Um obviously again not
making false statements and and having a
respect for the for the process in which
they were appointed to serve. Um section
six requires uh the city administration
to provide the proper levels of support
to each board commission authority um to
asssure compliance with policy and
applicable law as well. Um article 10 is
ultimately the ethics code where the
ethics code will go. Um there are some
provisions here that may or may not be
changed as you deal with your drafting
of that code through recommendations of
through and with recommendations from
yourselves and the ethics commission. Um
one of the things that I've done here is
just added uh two items that are not
specifically covered by the charter
which is the special privileges and
incompatible employment or activity. The
charter provisions tend to deal with
mostly the financial sort of um
impropriety and these are ones again
just to put in your thoughts and
ultimately the ethics commission's
thoughts as it considers these and again
confidential information. Um I've laid
out in section five a whole lot of the
things the charter already talks about
that should be coming and be and be
provided. I I would note that um what's
going to what I think is going to come
from the ethics commission are going to
be a lot of recommendations that are far
more detailed than these that deal with
procedure and operation. How is a
complaint filed? Who is it submitted to?
Who is it investigated by? How are
complaints uh how is confidentiality and
privacy protection protected during the
course of that process? What are the
penalties if any for a violation of the
act? um how are those penalties
enforced? There's a whole series of
things that theoretically should be in
an ethics code um that are not here and
not even not to you yet. Um you know, I
could take a stab at drafting them, but
but the ethics commission should weigh
in first. Um and that is the intended
action. And again, there are some places
here where things that weren't
necessarily covered by the charter um
and aren't always in an ethics code, but
could be. For example, confidential
information could or couldn't be. It
depends on on the particular body are
placed here for um you to start giving
thought because ultimately you do have
to draft an ethics code. Um and uh you
will be held to it uh as will um all
other appointed officials and employees.
Um so uh hopefully we'll have something
back for me from the ethics commission
um by the end of September and early
October as they do their work.
Um,
article 16, um, is mandated for
inclusion by the home rule charter law,
which is to start, which is to have a
section on employment and human
resources administration. A lot of what
you're going to see in this section, you
would expect to see and you would expect
the city to be doing. Um the specific
policies in most cases are left to um
the human resources bureau under the
direction supervision of the director of
administrative services and the mayor to
ultimately draft and implement. But the
requirements are essentially let's start
with require comply with law. You know
we have to comply with the federal
alphabet soup. Let's start with that.
You know you've got federal family
medical leave act. You've got ADA,
American with Disabilities Act. There's
a whole series of acronyms of laws,
EEOC, Equal Employment Opportunity
Commission. Um, so what you're going to
see as you go through here are um those
sorts of provisions. Couple notes in the
introduction part of this is that you
cannot supersede a collective bargaining
agreement. Um, as you may be aware, we
have we currently have three unions and
therefore have three separate collective
bargaining agreements. um their
provisions are not identical uh in so um
we can't supersede those uh and we have
to give we have to anything we adopt has
to be notwithstanding those um that
being said those are all meant to comply
with law but how we deal with policy
might be different with each of the
discipline would be an example of a of a
place where that rises um a great deal
of time is spent in section two
confirming and making sure it's clear
that employees are at will employees.
They they are subject to certain
constitutional rights, but they are
still at willill employees. And making
sure that no employee, manager or
supervisor can create a situation where
the city is now bound by a employment
contract. Um, and that's really a
protection for the city taxpayers to
make sure that we're not bound by an
employment contract. as as an employer,
the city wants to be able to move away
from employees lawfully that it's
entitled to move away from and not be
bound contractually to stay with them.
Um,
we move into again in general provisions
on being an equal employment opportunity
employer. Um, uh, prohibiting sexual
harassment and workplace violence.
um prohibiting retal pen retaliation and
any sort of retaliation for um you know
employees doing the right thing. Um
providing work accommodations where
they're um required by law. Um
paragraph F code of conduct for city
employees is essentially the rewrite of
our current code uh a current policy.
And again, I would expect that much of
this will either be removed and or moved
into the ethics code. I put it here only
because these are provisions that are
already existing in city policy so that
both you and the ethics commission can
see them as you do your work towards the
ethics code. Um, and I've added one or
two in paragraph three because obviously
we did not have an ethics code or a
charter when this policy was drafted. Um
but for the most part this is um a
document uh that city has as its policy
uh currently. Um so to put that here so
that everybody knew what already existed
what was in place um from a policy
standpoint and may or may not be
incorporated into the legislation.
Um social media is also part of that as
you page into the next page. Um the
policy actually combines both of those.
Um
paragraph G and that's the next page
there. I think um so paragraph G moves
into um authorizing the Bureau of Human
Resources to to adopt and implement
appropriate employment policies. Um
and you know covers a broad sort of
topics there and I mean
it the policy manual here is thick.
um as you might expect with 600 plus
employees um you know multiple types of
business operations for lack of a better
word when you talk about you know our
DPW functions, police functions, fire
functions, administrative functions,
planning functions. Um
we also require uh HR to establish a
complaint process so that employees can
file appropriate complaints if they
believe they're being treated improperly
and have them processed um both
effectively and efficiently and most
importantly in accordance with
applicable law uh to protect both the
employee and the city and and I say that
our policies are drafted to protect both
the employee and the city. Um and that
is a really key factor um is that
employees deserve the protection and to
make sure that they are treated
objectively across the board. come the
last section in this trunch of code um
which ultimately now is at about 60
pages and I expect will end up being uh
you know larger as we get into the
ethics code and add it in uh includes
some general provisions. One is um to
authorize uh to legislatively authorize
electronic signatures um which you know
currently would need to be is not in a
legislative process. I will tell you we
use them regularly. um I think most
business does these days. It's almost
impossible to process ink signatures
with some of the things the city does in
a timely manner. Um so that's here. Um
again authorizes the creation of fees.
You already approve fees annually uh
typically as two ways. Annually as part
of your budget and then whenever council
brings forth whenever the administration
brings forth an amendment to our fee
resolution. One of the things that this
does now is an affirmative burden on the
director of administrative services to
create a comprehensive fee schedule uh
and to maintain it uh in a clear manner
on the publicly accessible website. Um
so a and it directs the director of
administrative services to periodically
review um and arrange for their review
to make sure fees are in accordance with
um the services being provided, more
importantly the cost of the services
being provided. We do that typically
every several years and oftentimes
annually as part of the budget process,
but there's been no real legislative
requirement to do so. It's really been
sort of molded by practice as best
management practice and into the budget
practice. And here again, taking best
management practices and making sure
we're transparent that we're going to do
that is the recommendation.
Um, section three incorporates chapter
36 of our existing code dealing with the
city's ability to file municipal leans
and enforce city ordinances. Um, there
really isn't anything new here. Um, uh,
when you get to the attorney's fees,
those fees were listed. They had to be
put in place and I'm going thinking at
least 20 years ago. I'm not saying
they're wrong or right. They were put in
place when the city was using outside
council um regularly. Um
there's still a time and expense part to
uh preparing all of these things if the
city pursues a claim process or fee. Um
this is a way to make sure that there's
no shock and surprise to residents to
have it legislatively placed. Municipal
claims act requires that if you're going
to assess attorney's fees um in a
municipal claim that they have been
legislatively approved. So, if the fees
are updated, that's fine. But, um, you
do want to keep these because the
administration
um can use claims, municipal claims as
an optional form of enforcement of its
ordinances. Um, there was a time when
these were used very, very regularly.
Uh, and then there was a time when that
practice was discontinued. Uh, it's
really sort of the pleasure of the day
based on how the world is working in the
administration. What you don't want to
do is then create an not be able to
recover what you're entitled to recover.
So at least legislatively having it in
place to me is the right thing to do. Um
lastly um is section four which is the
publicly accessible website. And again I
mean I've kept this really clear. You
may want to include more specifics on
this as you go. Uh I've left this for
you to consider. Um but the the key
notices here are you know notices to be
posted thereon should be posted in a
conspicuous and easy to find manner.
Clear designation shall be given defined
posted rules and regulations promugated
by the city in accordance with this
administrative code. One thing I should
note is in the section you get to on
departments when you review that is
there is a provision that says
departments can promugate rules and
regulations.
Anytime they're promagating rules or
regulations that relates to a service
being provided to city residents, those
rules and regulations must be posted. Um
and so that's again making sure that
there's no sort of hidden rules and
regulations that people are only that
are only brought out sort of um when
needed versus in up front. Um so those
are the provisions that I've included
for your review. Uh again you'll get the
opportunity now to read these in detail.
Um uh obviously folks you can you can
send emails to me. I ask again uh to
email me directly not to email uh group
email so that we make sure that any
responses I might give I'll share
responses but I don't want um sort of a
discourse to go on. Um uh DJ will have
the um the portal open for questions
from the public. That's open tonight,
DJ.
Soon as the meeting is over um and will
be maintained open um quite frankly
until two weeks after our our next
meeting. So uh again for citizens to
pose questions and for you to see that
and for and for us to then respond to
those questions for you to see those
responses. Um
and And I'm again just going to
reiterate one last time. Um
I'm not the elected official here. Um I
I serve as council for the city as an
entity, which is a whole lot of cast and
characters, right? So I've got I've got
city council, I've got employees, I've
got the administration, um I've got all
the independent units of the city. What
I've tried to do in giving you the
entirety of this administrative code uh
is my best effort at giving you a good
starting point for what I think are good
practices. Um, good things to think
about. Um, it's up to you to decide
whether you want more or less. Um, and
to have debate about those topics. Um, I
feel fairly comfortable that what's here
uh would be a really good administrative
code. Um, that being said, it doesn't
mean it can't be improved and be made
flexible by made made by you to meet
what you as the elected council members
decide is most important.
So
the administration has worked hard to
try and find the same level of
objectivity that I've talked about. Uh
these provisions have been reviewed by
members of the administration in each of
their departments. Um we're not
objecting to the the ex the new
requirements that are put on them. Um
and there are new requirements put on
them. There's reporting requirements,
there's administrative requirements. the
budget process obviously is far more
detailed than it was just a year ago. Um
so this is all about, you know, what's
best for the city and its taxpayers. And
we turn this over to you and hopefully
with the next meeting we can have really
great discourse about some or all of
these provisions. And that that
concludes my my presentation for the
evening.
Thank you very much, Mr. Hburger. Um to
remind members of council that next
meeting is September 16th. That will be
our next work session. Um and as we did
in the last work session, we'll be going
through the sections and having
discussion um and looking for consensus
before uh this is presented as an
ordinance in a regular meeting of city
council. Um I just want to kind of
follow up and and ask because you know
the last section uh there was a lot of
consensus right off the bat. The the the
things were very clear I think. Um, if
members of council have specific
additions and edits that they would like
to present for discussion, uh, would you
prefer that that come to you, uh, for
the next meeting or would you prefer
that they hold them until we are in that
work session? I'm not sure what the best
way to present that would be. From my
perspective, um I don't need advanced
notice, but if council wants my opinion
on how's the best way to draft this, um
is this saying what I want it to say, uh
feel free to reach out to me. Um you
know, this is supposed to be discussion
amongst yourselves, but I'm here to help
facilitate that. So I I would encourage
my role as a facilitator. Um I'm not in
control of it. Um it's your document uh
to do with as you desire. Um, I'm happy
to take a review of anything you might
be proposing. Um, ideas you might be
proposing if you know if you'd rather
understand is is this going to be
allowed by law. Sure, reach out to me
before you get an answer of no or oh, I
have to research that. I might be able
to get the research done before the next
meeting. So, um, from that from I think
that if is that enough
the purpose of that question and of
course reaching out to you separately
again to avoid discussion which would
violate sunshine law. So yes,
thank you. And uh same with members of
the public um submitting those questions
and comments through the portal so that
we can be prepared to discuss them.
Although it will be open after the
meeting on the 16th, it would be best to
talk about them before the 16th if
possible. Um so thank you very much uh
for that this evening. Uh we will now
counselors move into public comment
during this meeting. It's open to uh
comments on the administrative code
sections that were presented this
evening. Comments are limited to three
minutes per speaker and must begin with
the speaker's name and block of
residence for our meeting record. If
anyone wishes to make public comment
this evening, you can please proceed to
the microphone at the end of the table.
And you may need just to turn that on.
Tony Dashra, 700 block of New Holland
Avenue. uh as you work through
advertising requirements,
I encourage you to have redundancy built
into the system. Um mentioned websites
going down, but newspapers being an old
style. Those two things working in
concert could be great. Um redundancy is
the reason we have two traffic lights on
one pole, so if one goes out, you don't
blow through a red light and kill
somebody. So redundancy in the
advertising I think in the 21st century
is necessary. And then on uh the note of
transportation metaphors,
as you work through
uh the city engineer, whether in this
document or otherwise, uh I encourage
you to prioritize the position of city
engineer to be given to somebody who has
municipal traffic engineering
certification as dictated by title 17,
title 67, chapter 212.
Uh and I encourage that because that
sort of certification empowers our city
to have more control over the traffic
control devices on state roads, reduces
the friction we need to friction or just
delay we have with PennDOT.
It allows us to for example change
signal timings to experiment. We don't
have to submit a report uh to ask
PennDOT to do it. We have to follow
their standards but it empowers the city
to do it themselves. Uh so those are my
two main things based off the
subject of tonight. Um
yeah, thank you.
Thank you very much. Are there any
additional comments from the public on
this evening's content?
Hearing none, we'll close public comment
this evening. And that is the end of our
agenda. Counselors, I'll hear a motion
to adjurnn.
Second.
Have a motion and a second. All in
favor?
I
I We arejourned. Thank you very much.